turno de la cultura en france 24 estoy
en ir a gómez muñoz y es un placer
saludarles saben que los artistas viven
resistiendo a la pandemia pero para los
creadores afganos esto nunca fue
prioridad no en gobierno bajo control
estadounidenses siempre en conflicto con
señores de la guerra y menos en manos
talibán su retorno como dibuja sham si
hasan y la 1ª grafitera del país es
desolación y crudeza sobre todo para las
mujeres y niñas para su heroína para que
retratar con hijab porque quitárselo no
supone libertad
aunque hassan y pone luz al riesgo de
los derechos humanos en afganistán hoy
publica la oscuridad de su escondite un
exilio que ahora buscan millones y que
antes sufrió la escritora malalai joya
por señalar a varios miembros del
parlamento o la novelista a nadia ghulam
que para huir hace 20 años de los
talibanes se pasó 10 bajo la identidad
de su difunto hermano entonces con ellos
miles de obras fueron saqueadas o
destruidas para ejemplo los budas de
bamiyán cuyo devenir tm el museo
nacional de kabul mientras que ya en
julio tirotearon y degollaron al
comediante en asar mohammad por burlas
en bailes y canciones del país y de la
realidad talibana además de trabajar
para la policía afgana ocho votos que
hay de nosotros simplemente vienen y nos
matan porque queremos ser libres porque
queremos ser iguales a cualquier mujer y
niño
si dan reconocimiento político a los
talibanes si los aceptan destruirán
nuestras vidas la vida de las mujeres
es afganistán es irán son todos esos
países donde la gente no puede irse
libremente y no entiendo la razón y por
supuesto soy una mujer y esto es muy muy
difícil de ver lo que está sucediendo
allí para las mujeres estoy muy
conmovida happening for women
puede que con annette la actriz francesa
nos lleve a un musical a una cinta de
paisaje teatral que desde el minuto 1 y
desde las bambalinas nos da las reglas
de su visionado
pero su historia dirigida por el
singular leos carax y escrita y
compuesta por los sparks trata de muchos
modos lo que venimos hablando miedo
machismo violencia vaya nos lo canta
revelando solo es necesario no se
enfrenta a un amor tóxico con un cómico
que en cuanto el éxito de su bella
cantante le toca su masculinidad revela
su verdadero rostro es fácil reconocer
la ambigüedad de la situación ya que
cotija y adam driver la encarnan entre
plátanos manzanas mordidas y alusiones
entre otros a cuentos no obstante el
riesgo y brillantez de caracas a ratos
excesivos van más allá mostrando
accesible mente los límites del humor y
lo correcto
[Música]
ya en otro tono esta semana recordamos
que 2021 es año bien al sur con la
tercera bienal de arte pensado desde
este hemisferio a partir de 400 artistas
y más de 124 sedes en 50 ciudades del
mundo
pero claro el cómic 19 como todo ha
hecho potenciar las escalas locales de
esta iniciativa surgida en 2017 en
argentina así como otras formas de
transmitir la experiencia de una obra
imposible de trasladar por el virus por
ello y nuestro corresponsal natalio cost
hoy nos guía dentro de la nación hasta
la urbe de san juan en la zona de cuyo
fronteriza con chile para indagar cómo
lo han hecho posible desde el museo
franklin rawson
estos dados de 100 kilos cada uno son
una referencia hiperbólica a las áreas
la pérdida de control sobre lo que nos
ocurre algo especialmente actual en este
contexto de pandemia son creación del
artista japonés yutaka son el artista no
está aquí pero si su obra es una
constante en esta edición de bien al sur
casi todas las piezas también los dados
se fabricaron aquí en san juan y esta
performance quedó escindida del artista
que la ideó el belga gert robin quien
tampoco está presente que está siendo
ejecutada por el colectivo de artistas
sanjuaninos proyecto baldío nos pareció
interesante en tomar la obra de un
artista que viene de afuera
reinterpretar la no y de alguna manera
trabajar como mano de obra aparece
artista para producir su obra en esta en
este lugar esto le otorga también a la
muestra un fuerte elemento local algo
que los creadores de bienes del sur
buscan darle a este gran evento global
si lo global no tiene lo local se
convierte en la globalización de los
grandes poderes en la globalización de
las grandes instituciones nosotros
estamos totalmente en contra de eso
además de vincular lo global y lo local
bien en el sur también establece un
puente entre el pasado y el presente
como ocurre en esta otra sede en la
ciudad de san juan en esta obra que es
un horno de barro especialmente
construido para la ocasión se va a
cocinar pan para repartir libremente es
la réplica de una obra de hace 50 años
del artista conceptual argentino víctor
grippo quien falleció en el año 2002 en
1972 grippo considerado padre del
conceptualismo argentino y
latinoamericano construyó un horno de
barro como éste en la capital de los
país buenos aires para hornear pan y
repartirlo en las calles la obra fue
censurada y destruida este horno menaje
es una de las tres obras de grupo que se
exhiben aquí en san juan que atraviesan
y vinculan entre otros los temas de la
alimentación el arte la naturaleza y la
comunidad una comunidad que en el caso
de bien al sur también una presencia
hacia ausencias
y presente lo local y lo global
a mi amiga
ven sanjuán del viaje de natalio nos
despedimos en lo que fuera villa epecuén
en la provincia de buenos aires pues es
allí sobre las ruinas de una ciudad que
quedó bajo el agua hace 36 años que las
argentinas miss bolivia y pero touching
o invocan juntas y de forma orgánica la
transformación del mundo hacia uno más
social menos como dicen sin lo
perturbador de nuestro presente
individual y en crisis humanitaria
gracias por su compañía y cuídense mucho
hasta pronto
de alta feliz miseria está destina te
mienten en la tele el odio mata el odio
muebles desde igualdad maldad
el odio que mantén realidad
[Música]
que quiero un mundo donde no para
vivir como quisiera pasar leer a cada
cual a su manera para mutar y que
podamos ser un mundo menos
[Música]